i'm going in on chelsea pierce so i
don't know if you guys know this chelsea
piers had
an event this past sunday uh with ron
desantis chelsea piers is in new york
city it's a sports complex center in new
york city it's in an area called chelsea
so that's between it's around 18th
street is the is the meat of it i think
it's between like 17th and 23rd which is
downtown manhattan and it's a sports
center that has everything right it has
you can go there and play any indoor and
outdoor sport you can you know use the
sky rink you can um have parties there
meetings there like it's a really cool
complex really outdoor golf with all
those big nets i mean it's really really
fun i've been there many many times
um over the past years fitness programs
everything swimming pools
so they have events and this past week
the tikvah fund i don't know if i'm
saying that right i asked my jewish
husband i said please pronounce this for
me and he said i don't know
jeremy so helpful i swear
he's like don't worry about it it's
close enough this is my husband what he
says to me okay
so this is the tikvah fund um they had
hosted an event
um and they invited ron desantis let me
tell you what the tikvah fund is just so
that you know it's a philanthropic
foundation this is from their website
ideas an ideas institution committed to
supporting the intellectual religious
and political leaders of the jewish
people and the jewish state
um and invests in a wide range of
initiatives and just an important note
in the second paragraph it says it's
politically zionist economically
free-market-oriented culturally
traditional and theologically
open-minded yet in all issues and
subjects we welcome vigorous debate and
big arguments so that's in the paragraph
that follows that
so they they
welcome debate they're free market
oriented it's not surprising to me that
they invited um
ron desantis to come in
and what happened was there was uproar
it's
shocking
so prior to the event
there was i noticed there was a
statement from chelsea pierce that was
released i believe this was friday via
their twitter account chelsea piers new
york city and this is what it says you
can put that up on the screen for you
i'm just going to go through a little
bit of it ron desantis planned
appearance
has caused enormous distress in our
company the lgbtq plus community and the
many organizations who consider pier 60
and chelsea piers their home i'm i'm
summarizing because you have the whole
thing on the screen the tikvah fund
booked its jewish leadership conference
at pier 60 over the past 24 years pure
60 has hosted hundreds of influential
and notable events they go on to say
you know they have all these different
types of events look at the last
paragraph having said that we could not
disagree more strongly with many of ron
desantis actions in office one response
to abhorrent behavior
what's his important behavior we'll get
to that in a second is to counter it
with positive action
accordingly pier 60 will direct every
dollar it receives from tikvah to groups
that protect lgbtq plus communities and
foster and amplify productive debates
about lgbtq plus issues that's their
statement they come out with this on
friday panic-stricken right because
they're getting complaints
from people so they decide we're gonna
we're gonna counter this we're gonna
come in we're gonna come in hot
so what is the apparent behavior
well
my guess is this is in response to the
don't say gay bill that doesn't exist
because there is no don't say gay in the
bill that came out of florida that was
controversial that's a media talking
point that they invented what that bill
is is a parental rights bill that
read the bill and we will get to that
bill in greater detail at some point
because i want to go back and reference
it with respect to something else but
it's a bill that really advocates for
parents to be informed of what's going
on when it comes to the mental and
physical well-being of their children in
classrooms
it also says that you shouldn't be
talking about sex and sexualized content
with
small children up till third grade so
you're talking kindergartners
preschoolers first graders
that's what the bill says
if you think that sex should be
discussed in preschool you have a
problem the problem is not with the bill
the problem is with you
regardless it was labeled the don't say
gay bill and of course the group
thinkers over at chelsea piers decided
not to read the bill and instead to buy
whatever you know msnbc or media matters
or whoever it was decided they were
going to say it was don't say gay don't
get great talking point whoever created
that and disseminated it through media
it's also a lie but so is most of what
they say
so in addition
libs of tick tock i found had a scoop
over the weekend and they said that
chelsea piers sent this email to their
employees so not only did they put the
statement out
they had to put that statement out and
say don't worry all the funds are going
to things that we all agree with don't
worry
we're also going to talk to our
employees here's what we're going to say
they're going to apologize for any hurt
and suffering that may have been
involved due to this decision making i'm
not exaggerating so here's the the
letter i don't know if you have that one
from lives of tick tock uh tyler if you
don't it's fine i'm gonna read from it
chelsea piers it says the jewish leader
i'm skipping down to the middle the
jewish leadership conference has chosen
to schedule speakers who hold views and
policies
related to the lgbtq plus community that
are not shared by chelsea peers many in
our community and we assume
we assume a vast majority of our chelsea
pierce team members and then if you skip
to the bottom we understand that the
presence of controversial speakers at
pier 60 may hurt some of those dearest
to us in our community for that
we are truly sorry
what a bunch of babies will someone get
them blankies and pacifiers for the
adults
are you kidding me
i wish i could say i was surprised i'm
not
what i love about this is the line that
says many in our community and we assume
we assume that all of you agree right
because how can it be any differently in
the group think bubble that is new york
city
of course if you come to chelsea piers
you must agree with all these things and
if you work here you must write or
you're bigoted right right
right
okay
and they had to apologize for the pain
and suffering that was endured
okay so let me say this bluntly if you
experience pain and suffering
over someone coming to speak
that you disagree with then you are
a child you're not an adult
and you are mentally unhealthy
yes
because adults are able to listen to
differing viewpoints and not crawl into
a safe space and be coddled
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]